okay everyone we're going to get
started um so welcome to this lecture uh
this is the second lecture in our course
AI in The Sciences engineering um in
this lecture I'm going to be covering an
introduction to deep learning and so
this is uh the first part of two
lectures on this
subject so before I do that let's just
recap what I covered in the last lecture
in the last lecture I gave you a very
high level motivation of the course and
introduction to the
course and what I hopefully tried to
show you was that AI is really having a
massive impact in science and as and is
driving a lot of breakthroughs uh today
so I talked about examples from uh you
know using AI to carry out really fast
and accurate climate simulations and
weather predictions I also showed you an
example of using AI to help control
Fusion in nuclear
reactors um and and AI can also help us
predict much much fast much more fast um
the the the 3D structure of
proteins um I also talked about the kind
of key scientific tasks that we often
want to solve when we're doing
scientific research and I also try to
motivate the ways that AI could help us
solve those so for example helping us
solve simulation tasks uh maybe making
them more efficient or faster to run
helping us solve inverse problems um
understanding underlying parameters from
observations of of a system um perhaps
AI can help us more accurately determine
those parameters and then I also talked
about equation Discovery and and instead
of relying on human intuition can we can
we have an AI learn kind of to to
discover unknown physics for
example okay and then I also try to
introduce this field which is called
scientific machine learning and this is
kind of the stateoftheart of using AI in
scientific research today and it's and
and this field this because we realize
there are many disadvantages of using
machine learning or or or maybe flaws of
machine learning for example lack of
interoperability the amount of training
data that we
require uh and so what we try and do in
this field is really tightly blend our
existing scientific understanding with
ml to make models that are more powerful
more robust uh more
interpretable okay so uh yeah here's the
course timeline that I showed last
lecture so we're on the second lecture
like I said the first lecture of two on
an introduction to deep
learning so what we're going to cover in
this lecture um it's a it's a fairly
high level um covery of deep learning
and so first I'm going to explain what
deep learning is and I'm going to
explain multi-layer perceptrons one of
the most basic noral Network
architectures there is I'm also going to
talk about the universal approximation
uh of deep noral networks then I'll talk
about the the popular tasks that we use
uh deep learning for so things like
supervised learning uh unsupervised
learning these are kind of classic
machine learning tasks that we that we
want to
solve and then uh last I'll talk about
how we train uh deep noral networks and
in particular uh gradient descent back
propagation
okay so yeah by the end of the lecture
hopefully you'll be able to
mathematically Define what a deep neural
network is you'll be able to understand
the typical types of tasks that we use
newal networks for and um explain how
they're trained as
well and then by the end of these two
lectures um you I should have covered
enough material that you'd be able to
explain um at a bit lower level how chat
GPT you know this super popular model or
more generally how large language models
uh uh are trained and also the
architecture that they use and you
should be able to understand uh how
these
work
okay so just to start off uh at a really
high level and this is a slide that I
showed again in the in the course
introduction um AI research has really
exploded in the last decade or or more
um and I showed examples of AI impacting
the world today and I I just talked
about chat GPT we have now large
language models that can have
conversations with us and and do really
remarkable things we also have AIS that
can generate really realistic images and
videos now um we have AIS that can do
multitask uh can solve multiple tasks at
the same time so for example gate is
able to uh classify images and have a
conversation with you and play games um
and uh AI underpins a lot of the
technologies that we use today so uh for
example uh Speech translation or text uh
language translation also helps us Co
code Co copilot for
example um and the the technology that
is really driving AI research and has
driven AI research or or I would say 90
99% or maybe 90 90% is uh deep
learning
um and so why why is deep learning so
popular um well again this is the slide
that I showed in the introduction there
are broadly three main reasons the first
is there is a lot more data in the world
today that these uh we can train these
algorithms on uh Hardware Improvement
has improved so uh we can uh train much
bigger much bigger
models um and also there's a lot more
software out there today that makes it
really easy to train neural networks so
we have pytorch tensor flow and also a
lot more architectures and a lot more
innovation in in in uh in the theory
behind these models as
well okay so before before I explain uh
deep learning specifically I want to
just put it in the context of the
broader field of
AI so AI machine learning deep learning
these are terms that are used fairly
vaguely today or kind of hard to Define
sometimes or people have different uh
definitions of
them but what I'm going to say is uh or
what's important to realize is that
machine learning and deep learning is
one specific part of of AI and for the
purpose of this course I would define AI
as you know an TR training an
intelligent agent to be able to M mimic
human human
behavior and and learning about the
world kind of learning about the rules
of the world is just one aspect of of
what I would expect an AI system to be
able to do you can imagine like once
you've learned some rules you don't just
want to know those rules you want to be
able to do something about it so for
example if you if you've learned a lot
of mathematical logic statements about
the world you might want to infer things
from those statements or if you've
learned about Transport Systems you
might want to be able to then plan a
route from A to B so so learning is just
one part of autonomous
system um so machine learning is
concerned about learning the rules of
the world and then deep learning itself
is a just a specific part of machine
learning which is using specifically
deep noral networks to learn learn
patterns or learn these
rules so yeah we're going to focus a lot
on deep learning but it's really
important to appreciate this this wider
field and and if you're interested in
getting into AI more generally I there's
a lot of really great material out there
the one that I would recommend is this
book uh a modern approach from Russell
and norvic this is a kind of classic
textbook which gives you a wider um
introduction to
AI okay so um if there's one thing that
I want you to take away from from this
lecture um is is this this idea and it's
the idea that Neal networks are very
simply just flexible functions that are
fit to data so that that's quite a
simplistic view of of newal networks and
of course there's a whole Variety in
many different architectures and a lot
of complexity when training networks but
this is really useful especially when
we're going to apply uh noral networks
to Scientific problems this is a very
useful way of thinking of them so what
do I mean by that so so it's very simply
the neural network takes some input and
this input is usually a vector X it
passes it through some mathematical
function um the normal Network
architecture itself defines that
function um and that architecture has
some free parameters Theta that we're
going to we're going to tune and then
the network produces an output Y which
again is another
vector and what the training process of
the network is to try and match those
outputs of the network to some training
data by tuning the values of
theta um so an example a very simple
example um would just be you know given
this data here so this is uh noisy
measurements of of of some data sample
from just a polinomial for
example given those y values uh can we
produce a function that fits fits that
curve basically so it's simple curve
fitting
um uh and so uh yeah that that's exactly
it neural networks are simply flexible
functions that are fit to
data okay so I hope that most of you
know about function fitting already and
have done have done function fitting
before um and kind of uh if we just
assume that this data here is just from
a polom then you know the classic way of
doing it is just to do polinomial
aggression or or or actually just linear
aggression this is something that
hopefully everyone has seen
before so how would we do it if we if we
were just going to do linear regression
how would we do function
fitting so first we would just assume a
model of the data so we would say okay I
I'm going to assume that these data
points are follow a polom curve so y hat
is our approximation of the of the true
function and uh the only thing is we
don't know what the coefficients of the
polom are so these Theta 1 Theta 2 theta
3 Theta
4 so one way to frame this is to to say
um I'm going to use least squares to to
estimate what Theta um are so I'm going
to choose a Theta star my best guess of
what Theta is by minimizing the least
squared difference between what my model
predicts and and my my noisy train
training
measurements okay so this is just Le
squares regression and we can just
rewrite this using linear algebra so so
um we can say that all of the outputs
all the predictions of my model these y
hats for each training data point um
just equals this Matrix which is um our
values of X and their powers Times by
our Vector of or our column Vector of of
thetas
and then we can rewrite our least
squares objective as minimizing Theta in
this in this Matrix equation and you can
show for this polinomial or linear
aggression case um there's an an
analytical solution so you can compute
this analytically and it just involves
Computing an inverse of this of this
five
Matrix okay great so so hopefully that's
something you should be very familiar
with so how is normal Network regression
different well to be honest it's very
very
similar it's exactly the same idea where
we have you know again some function
some neural network function which we're
going to try and fit to this
data and typically a very popular U uh
you know method again is to use least
squares and we're going to use exactly
the same objective where we're going to
say the outputs of the nor
network uh or the difference between the
outputs of the nor Network and my
training data should should be minimized
and we'll choose a Theta value that
minimizes that
so really the only difference here is
that in general I haven't told you what
that neural network function is and if
we don't know uh what that function is
in general we don't have an analytical
solution and so we have to resort to
some other way of learning those
parameters of the network and so you
know 99% of the time we we use gradient
descent to train train deep n networks
and so that involves taking the
derivative of this uh this loss function
with respect to the weights of the
network um and then a gradient descent
step with some some learning
rate um so yeah that's that's it that's
a very simple description of how we
train neural networks and and this is
the case for nearly every neural network
that we
train so the next question really is
okay so what exactly is that function
that we're defining noral network of X
and as I said this is just depends on
the specific noral Network architecture
that you choose
and the one that I'm going to cover in
detail is this multi-layer perceptron so
this is probably one of the most basic
architectures uh uh that has been around
for the longest um for in or
network uh MLPs come can be defined with
many with a varying number of layers but
for a two two layer MLP the actual
equation for it is is given below here
and so we take our input X we times it
by some weight Matrix we add a bias
vector pass it through an activation
function this is a sigma value and then
uh do the same process again depending
on how many layers we have of the of the
network um and yeah that's that's the
the simple mathematical definition of of
an
MLP so um you have to ask the question
like why why do we choose that
particular function like there are so
many different functions we could choose
with with free parameters in like what
why does everyone use this this
particular function it seems a bit
arbitrary well I mean the reason why we
use neural networks and these functions
is uh is because noral networks are
inspired uh by biology I mean this is
the reason why this field started is
because we wanted to train algorithms
that were more like how the brain brain
works and so there's a a caveat there
that noral networks definitely a very
simple approximation to the brain and
what the brain does is much much more
complicated than this but it's it's a
good analogy at
least um and so uh so if I took just a
single Neuron a single output neuron of
the MLP here for the last layer and I
just draw the um how it processes its
inputs and pass and gives you its output
you can see that it takes the
activations from the previous neurons
times times times as it by these scaler
weights sums it together adds the bias
and passes it through in
activation and this is indeed need kind
of a simple uh uh view of how a
biological neuron would work so you know
this is a diagram of a neuron it has has
some inputs here that are being
activated it processes those inputs and
and produces a spike depending on their
values and then passes it to the to to
neurons further further
Downstream so this is kind of similar to
what a neuron is doing in a in a neuron
Network and so then if I if I this is
just for a single neuron in the last
layer if I if I write an expression for
both the neurons and the last layer I
can actually just turn that into a
matrix equation where I put my weights
uh inside this Matrix here times them by
all the activations from the from the
from the previous layer and add this
bias vector and then you can see how we
can arrive at this equation that I
explained before that defines the noral
network function
itself um and so to add more layers we
just compose uh each these layers
together and we can just say that the
nor function is just a composition of
these layers functions these G gnf
functions then the final thing I haven't
really talked about is the actual
activation function itself um and so
there are many different choices that
you can make of the activation function
the probably the most popular one that
is used is the relo activation function
which is just zero when the summation
here is less than zero and otherwise the
value of the summation if it's greater
than
zero we're going to be covering a few
different activation functions in the
course of course one that we use a fair
amount for scientific work is uh is tan
or or more generally uh continuous or
smooth smoothly varying activation
functions so for example in in physics
and formal networks these these are very
useful and we'll explain why in in that
lecture so yeah I've given you all the
all the the tools necessary to be able
to train this train the neural network
Define it and train it
um and so this is just an example of of
a MLP uh given by this function here uh
fitting fitting to this training data
that I I I've been showing
you and uh you can see as it trains it
starts to it starts off at a very kind
of smooth function that doesn't vary
much and slowly fits to the data and so
this is an animation of the of the fun
the function estimated by the network as
as a function of training
step and I just think it's really
interesting to see how these these
things Evol and Train sometimes it's
kind of hard to understand exactly why
it trains in a certain way one really
interesting thing you can do is uh plot
the weights of each uh you know the
weights for each neuron and how they
evolve over over training step or over
time so this little animation on the
right the width of the line just is just
proportional to the to the the absolute
value of the
weight so what's kind of interesting as
you can see even though this is a very
simple function uh the the the output is
is a a summation o over the over a
distribu like is distributed over these
over the hidden neurons so it's not like
a single neuron is is is just producing
the
output and so this this actually is the
reason why neural networks are actually
sometimes very hard to interpret because
because of this kind of distributed
representation that they
learn okay so it does kind of beg the
question like if I'm doing like simple
curve fitting a polom curve fitting why
wouldn't I just use uh linear regression
so can anyone give me an answer why why
it's a good idea to use a neural network
for function
fitting yeah go
on yeah yeah
definitely so the clue is in in the
title so it's this property of noral
networks called Universal
approximation so what does that mean so
noral networks are just simp flexible
functions that fit to data but what's
special about them and what's different
to say like polom or linear aggression
is that with enough parameters and I'm
saying this in a very imprecise way but
this can be much more formalized you
know using mathematical Theory with
enough parameters normal networks can
approximate any arbitrarily complex
function and this is the universal
approximation property of of
networks so this is really really really
great and what makes deep learning so
powerful and what makes deep learning
applicable to all these different tasks
that it's been applied to you know
today so I I can learn not just simple
function fitting but I can learn really
complicated functions for example the
function that takes an image to like a
classification of what that image is
this can still be thought of as an image
how can how is an image this can still
be thought of as as a function so how
can an image be thought of as a as a
vector well it's quite easy you could
just imagine each pixel each value of
the pixel in the image is just an
element of the of the
vector and the classification um is just
we just interpret the the output of the
network as a as a
class um and so yeah this is a really
really great property of of neural
networks and this is what makes them so
powerful is that we can train them to do
many many different types of tasks which
Pro probably a linear model wouldn't be
able to do
and so what makes it
nonlinear uh rather than just a linear
function well it's it's the activation
functions you can see if we if we just
went back to this uh definition of a
noral network here what happens if I
just took out the activation function so
I I didn't pass it through any
activation function what would happen
anyone tell me
yep yeah yeah so a matrix Times by
matrix is another Matrix you just
collapse it into one linear function and
and so if you do like a classification
without activation functions for example
you'll just fit like a a linear
classification to to this data so it
really is these activation functions
that allow you to draw these kind of
nonlinear uh relationships between
between your
data okay so we talked about MLPs so I'm
going to try and explain to you a
different type of architecture now which
is the convolutional nor Network um and
I explain why is useful to use different
architectures than just a standard
MLP so we're going to take this example
again of a of classifying an
image and we're just going to think
about if we used an MLP just the number
of parameters that we would need to just
to do a simple classification
task so as I said before we could think
of the input image here is just a vector
where we flatten out the image and each
pixel value is is an element of that
Vector but that already is a really
massive Vector like if we have the
imagees 128 by 128 so a very small image
uh then you remember that each uh layer
in the in the MLP is fully connected so
each each neuron is fully connected to
all of the previous
neurons then you can work out the the
size of the first weight matric is going
to have to be assuming there's 100 uh um
neurons in the first layer it would be
100 times by 128 time 128 so this is
already 1.6 million parameters just in
the first layer of the network in so
that's a huge amount of of layers to do
a fairly simple classification
task so it doesn't really feel like an
MLP is the right architecture to use and
is very likely to over fit to this data
given the amount of parameters it
has so how is a convolutional noral
network different well it's used for the
same task so we're still going to
classify the image but the way that the
neurons see the input is
different and so
again we have a hidden layer of the
first hidden layer of neurons here and
we we lay them out so that they have the
same shape as the
image um and the important difference is
that each neuron neuron in that hidden
layer only sees a few neighboring values
in the in the input
image so for example it sees like a 3X3
or a 2 by 2 x two patch of the image and
so then this noron here is not connected
to the entire image and so therefore has
many less weights that we're multiplying
the image with to get that activation of
that
neuron um the other really important uh
difference of convolutional networks is
that each neuron here shares the same
weight values so they all apply the kind
of same filter to the to their patch
that they see in the image so this this
dramatically reduces the number of of
Weights uh inside each layer of the
convolutional network in fact for
example if the if each neuron just just
saw a 3X3 pack pure the image then you
would just have 3 * three weight 3 * 3
which is nine weights in in the network
that's dramatically different to you
know 1 point however many million
weights in the in the
MLP so mathematically we can just write
this as a as a cross correlation and and
this is the expression and it looks
similar to how a fully connected Network
would look it's just that we're we're
doing a summation over this over this
filter um and CNN's uh really good
choice for other reasons too they have a
lot of interesting properties and the
one that is most known is their their
translational
equarian and so this is the idea that
you
know the the the the head of dog the
head of the dog for example would give
you the same activation no matter no
matter where the the head is placed so
there's translational equivariance to
the to the input
image sounds strange
is it the radiators or is it the
blinds hard to say okay I'll try and
carry on
anyway uh so in practice uh we usually
extend cnns to have multiple input
channels and multiple output channels so
for example the the image of the dog uh
usually has like a red green and blue uh
channel to it um and so we can do the
same with the with the each layer of the
convolutional Network as well it can
have multiple channels and then what we
say is each neuron in each channel is
not only connected to the to a single
channel in its input but also all the
other channels too so you just build out
the the weight Matrix um and sum over
the channel channel Dimension as well
and so so that's the extra summation
that we're adding here in in our in our
layer
function so this gives us a few more
weights but makes the the network more
expressive and it can learn features
across different input channels
you can also extend CNN's to their 1D 3D
or even ND equivalents as well you can
see how that how that would be would
follow
analogously and yeah there's a lot of
innovation on on other tricks for cnns
like for example adding dilations not
having uh noral networks connected to
every single uh neighbor but maybe every
other neighbor uh and strides uh
similar so really interesting thing uh
that was realized quite early when we're
training cnns is that actually the depth
the depth really
matters so a good question is um how big
does the does the noral network need to
be how many parameters do we need to
have to be able to train the network um
and it for to be able to perform well
and be able to classify images well well
it actually turns out that a really
important um uh thing to do is to train
a deeper noral Network and not just a
wider noral Network so not just to have
more and more channels or more and more
uh hidden neurons but to have more and
more composed
functions and what you can do is like
query each kind of layer of the of the
convolutional network to see what it
responds to in it in its in its patch
and what we can see is that the first
layers of the convolutional network
respond to kind of very simple features
for example edges and Curves in the
input image but then as you get deeper
and deeper down uh into the into the
network you can see it starts to uh be
sensitive to more and more complex
features so you know going from maybe
things that look like ears and noses to
entire
faces so CNN's or Neal networks are
really powerful at learning these like
complicated
features um so you can even you can do
this more numerically and and and plot
the performance so the test accuracy of
different new network designs so for
example like a fully connected network
with just with just three three layer or
a convolutional network with three
layers or 11 layers and you really see
that it's the depth that matters in in
the accuracy of the network and not just
the number of parameters that the
network
has um so what does this mean what we're
really doing in a very general sense is
encoding into the network function like
a prior or an inductive bias we call it
and this inductive bias is the uh you
know the the true function that we're
trying to model is is a composition of
simpler functions and this is kind of a
powerful idea in what is the type of
inductive bias that we're encoding into
our noral Network
architecture okay so I've I've given you
a brief overview or recap of of what uh
newal networks are and and how we train
them so now I'm going to go through some
of the popular deep learning tasks that
we often train nor networks
on um so in particular I'm going to talk
about supervis supervised learning and
I'm going to cover regression and and
and
classification then I'm going to talk
about unsupervised learning and feature
learning Auto regression and generative
models but I think I want to go back to
this point that I said at the start in
all of these cases even though we have
maybe a different objective in a
different different way that we use our
training data in all cases the noral
network is still a function that is fit
to some some data some data
objective so supervised learning um so
this is where we have some typically we
have some inputs and we have some labels
or outputs of the function that we want
to that we want to model uh so uh in
regression it's a it's a continuous
function uh uh that that we want to
model and as I said before the setting
here is we have a set of inputs and
outputs example inputs and outputs uh
from from some true function or maybe
some noisy observations of that true
function and then we're going to use use
a mean squ error as our loss function or
or or our objective function uh to
minimize to estimate the weights of the
network
okay so what's very useful is to frame
this um as a pro from a probabilistic
perspective as well um and this this can
really help us interpret how how the
network is learning and also deal with
this kind of the in the situation where
we have some noisy um data data rather
than exact measurements of the function
for
example so how would you PR frame this
from a probabilistic perspective so you
would say well instead of trying to fit
a function what we actually have uh some
y value some some conditional
distribution so you know why these y
values are sampled from this
distribution given the values of X and
we actually want to approximate the
conditional distribution itself and
we're going to say there's some values
of theta here that we want to find that
best approximates this distribution
so how how would we how would we train
the network from a probabilistic
perspective so often we make we have to
make some assumptions and and like a
common one in this setting is to just
assume that this conditional
distribution is just a normal
distribution where the mean of that
normal distribution is the output of the
normal Network given the value of x and
then maybe the standard deviation is
just a a single number or we could try
to learn that as well
sometimes then we have to make a couple
more assumptions we say that the
training data or each training data
point here is independently and
identically uh sampled from the same
distribution so from the same normal
distribution and that allows us to write
the probability of our entire data set
so the probability that we observe X1 y1
X2 X Y2 Etc given our values of theta
and we can write it out in this with
this
product and then we just use a very
simple technique in statistics which is
ma maximum likel likelihood estimation
and that's just to say that
uh we're going to guess that our best
values of theta here are the values
which maximize the probability of the
data given the value of
theta so how do we maximize uh this
expression here uh well we given that
this is a normal distribution we can
just uh put in a normal distribution
here and then you can see quite quite
quickly that the maximization of theta
here is the minimization of of this
expression here which is the same as the
loss function we used before so it's
it's a really nice way to
to interpret loss functions from a
probabilistic perspective and depending
what distribution you choose changes the
the loss function that we use to train
the
network okay so let's move on to
classification so how is classification
different to regression well from a
probabilistic perspective um we're still
trying to estimate a conditional
distribution which is you know given the
value of x what's the value of y but
from a classification perspective this
distribution is now a discrete probably
distribution rather than a continuous
distribution so we assume that Y is a
sample from from some finite class of
possible values of Y so for example in
this in this very simple image
classification task we can say Y is
either a dog or it's a cat so there's
only two possible classes that it could
be so how do we how do we Define an
appropriate loss function in this case
if we want to train this
network so one way to do it is just to
say each class is going to be encoded as
a one one hot Vector what does that mean
it just means that if uh if the output
is a dog then we're just going to say
why is this Vector 01 and if it's a cat
then it's the the one zero Vector
instead um and then we again we have to
assume some form of this conditional
distribution so we'll say now it's just
the output of the network itself is just
going to represent the probability of
that
class uh given by this this expression
here uh and you can see how that would
the the probability is just uh uh
just um because this is a one hot Vector
it just pulls out the probability um for
example if this noron
sorry if if this neuron here tells us
the probability of the dog then this
product here is just going to pull out
that probability because it's a one hot
vector and we have to make sure that uh
to make sure our probabilities are all
correct is that the the summation over
the outputs of the of the network should
equal one so that we have a well-
defined
distribution okay and then uh we do
exactly the same workflow so we use
maximum likelihood likelihood estimation
again we assume that each of our
training data points um is identically
um and independently distributed and
then we can write out our probability of
our data in in this way
again and then it's the same idea so we
we maximize the probability of the data
given given the value of theta and we
end up eventually with a minimization of
this of this expression and this is
known as cross cross entrop in and uh
yeah that's the standard standard loss
function for training
classifiers okay so um oh one other
thing I said before we had to make sure
the outputs sum to one and so the
typical way that we do this is we use a
softmax output layer in of the network
to enure that and so we just say the
final activation here is uh is
normalized by the summation over the
outputs and that makes sure that it sums
to
one okay so let's move on to
unsupervised learning tasks uh and so
again remember I said newal networks are
functions fit to data and it's the same
thing here it's just the data that we're
fitting the the network to is slightly
different so we don't have like explicit
labels and explicit inputs we just have
some data set and we're we're going to
try and learn some function that learns
something like in the middle of that
data set
somehow so so for example uh Feature
Feature learning is is is one
unsupervised technique and it's the idea
that we can take an image and we can say
well actually that image can be
compressed into a lower dimensional
space that contains uh you know each
element of that space is like a Salient
feature of that image so maybe we could
describe images of dogs by by like the
color of the thir and the size of their
head for example and they're like two
Salient features that we could learn
learn to describe images
with so in this setting we have a noral
network which will compress the image
down into just a like a vector which is
much smaller than the the input vector
and then decompress it back outwards
again and we have a loss function which
just matches the output of the network
uh to the input of the network so to
reconstruct the
image and just by doing this we can
force the network to learn like a
Salient representation which which is
very useful for for further Downstream
tasks so for example if we want to do
some sort of clustering of the images or
or some some extra task on
top um so a good example of this a
variational autoencoders so this this
frames it in a fully probabilistic
framework um and it's really good at
discovering these kind of latent latent
variables so for example if we train a
vae on um on nness which is just lots of
images of digits and we just use two
salient you know we use a vector here
with just two elements in the in the
middle latent vector and we we we then
um sample those values across their
ranges and see what the output of the
vae gives us we can see that the you
know they learn to smoothly interpolate
between different numbers in in the data
set okay so kind of related to that
feature learning like reconstruction of
the data is uh autor regression this can
be thought of as an unsupervised
learning
task so instead of just reconstructing
the whole data the the goal here is to
to predict forwards what will happen in
the data so it's a prediction task so
there are many different examples of
Auto regression one is for example
predicting stock prices if you given the
previous price from the last like 10
days can you predict tomorrow's price or
another example of these large language
models like Chachi BT where they're
given a sentence or like part of a
sentence and then the goal is to
complete the next word in the
sentence so the task is G given many
example sequences train a model to
predict the future values from from the
past
values um so this is how one noral
network architecture might work this is
a a recur a recurrent neural
network so you can imagine uh X we have
our our previous values x0 X1 X2 X3 we
pass them into the network and they're
processed uh you know by some some
network module and I'm not going to be
specific about what that is but it could
be for example convolutional networks or
MLPs or something like that and then we
run we uh run these networks recursive
recurrently through time and then
produce outputs after that to predict
the next the next
values okay then the final kind of class
of unsupervised learning algorithms that
I'm going to talk about are generative
models um and so again this is this is
another type of task given some training
data so so given many examples of of of
uh X's here so some some training data
set what I now want to do is learn a
distribution or or more more
specifically I want to be able to sample
from the distribution that those those
examples came
from so an example would be if we have
lots of images um I want to be able to
sample a new image from that
distribution that's never perhaps been
seen
before um and so yeah image generation
is is one example and one way you might
do this is you might have a something
called a generative network uh which for
example might take like a random random
Vector as a seed as the input and given
that random Vector it will process it
into into an image there are many types
of generative networks out there and and
ways to train generative models um and
one of the most famous ones called
generative adversarial Networks
and uh these these generative networks
look like this kind of architecture but
the way that they're trained they also
have uh a discriminator which which
helps to train the generative network uh
by telling you or guessing whether that
image has been generated or whether it's
A True True
Image
um so yeah I've given just a very brief
and quick overview of the different
types of tasks that we that we train
noral networks to solve and and there
are many of many tasks like this in
scientific research that we want to
solve and so it's it's very useful to
understand all these different
techniques okay in in the last couple of
minutes I'm I'm going to talk a little
bit more about training deep neural
networks and in particular um how we use
gradient to Center train train the
networks in more
detail um so yeah I already said this
before um again most
task that we're using neural networks
for we're trying to fit a function to
data and we just we use some sort of
loss function um sometimes it's the
squared sometimes it's something else
and in general there's no analytical
solution that will let us minimize that
loss function um and so we have to use
we often use gradient descent and this
is the kind of algorithm of choice for
for most training
tasks so um the question is how do we
actually computationally uh compute uh
this the derivative of the Lost function
with with respect to Theta and that's
that's kind of an interesting question
that's worth
exploring so um what we do is we utilize
the chain rule basically to to be able
to evaluate this gradient um and so you
know given this lease squared loss
function we can already apply the chain
rule once to to to show very easily that
DL by D Theta is just you know two times
the network output minus the True Value
Times by the derivative of the network
with respect to
Theta okay so so we've applied the chain
rule once to to to get the to to
evaluate the the
gradient so now we have to bring in the
actual nor Network function itself so
let's just assume that it's a fully
connected Network here that's composed
of these lay these layer functions uh
you know very simple weight weight
matrices Times by the input plus the
bias so the next question is how do we
calculate what is the derivative of the
network with respect to say one of the
Theta values so the W
W1 so how how would you go about or how
how can we derive that does anyone
know how would how would someone go
about finding the derivative of this
function with respect to
W1 uh yep go on chain roll yeah but what
makes it a little bit
harder than just a simple chain rule
I mean that is the answer
but yeah yeah so this is a multivariate
problem because uh this function the
output of this function is in general a
vector and the input is also a vector
and we've got matric multi
multiplications so what we have to
do is do yeah multivariate chain
R and uh to do that we can evaluate this
DM by
dw1 um but this object here is not a
Scala Scala is actually a matrix a
Jacobian to be more precise which is a
matrix which contains the derivative of
the each component of the output with
respect to each component of the of the
weight Matrix so this is depending on
how big W1 is and the output of the
network this can actually be a really
massive Matrix with a lot of values in
it for example if this weight Matrix has
a million values in this is going to
have like a million uh rows I
guess um so uh or sorry a million
columns looking at the
definition so yeah we have to apply the
multivariate
cham so I can actually write this down
anal analytically and I don't I don't
have the time to explain this in the
lecture but you can go away and and
write this down and uh prove it for
yourself if I use the multivari chain
rule then this is the expression for the
for the gradient with respect to
W1 um and it just involves derivatives
of my activation function and the weight
matrices and the values of of of X and
and the intermediate activations of the
of each
layer so then we can just finally
compute DL by dw1 so that L is a
summation over all the examples so we
have this summation in the final
gradient and it's this expression
here um and so the way that modern
Frameworks for doing deep learning like
P torch and tensorflow work is they use
this Alor called back propagation to
evaluate these gradients of the loss
function with respect to the the
trainable parameters of the
network and back propagation does exact
evaluates exactly this
expression um and for efficiency reasons
and we're going to get much more into
detail in this in the in the second half
of the course when we talk about
differentiable physics and autod
differentiation in much more detail um
for efficiency reasons it evaluates this
expression from left to right this means
that we can do
uh vector vector Jacobian products
instead of big Matrix Matrix multiplies
which are very impossible to
compute um so yeah we evaluate this from
uh from left to right and so how these
algorithms work or or the
differentiation works is that we do a
forward pass first where we where we
evaluate the output of the network and
store all the intermediate activations
and then we do a backwards pass where we
compute the the gradient from from those
from those
values um
yeah and I've just shown you the
gradient with respect to W1 you can
derive similar expressions for all the
other all the other parameters of the
network so yeah in practice we're going
to use Auto differentiation to do all of
this stuff for us and we don't have to
worry about this when we're practically
coding noral networks all we have to do
is Define the forward function of the
model and auto differentiation pytorch
tensorflow will be able to evaluate that
gradient and help you train that model
automatically using autoi
okay so uh that's the end of this
lecture because we're it's a a short
lecture today um so just to summarize
the main thing I want you to take away
is that noral networks are simply
flexible functions that fit to
data the magic of noral networks is that
they have Universal approximation they
can be trained on many many different
tasks and we train them using the
gradient uh the chain Rule and gradient
descent So yeah thank you very much and
see you see you next time
[Applause]